le alors patrick c'est le dialoguiste
qui sort ça va être ta fête et non plus
de faire la fête ce soir encore dans
touche pas au poste alors 4x venait avec
côté de moi on va chanter la fiesta
ensemble j'ai vu vous avez balancé il
peut faire entrer ce qu'ils veulent je
pense de l'électronique a two way
enlever la neige peu les chroniqueurs je
vous rappelle tout ce qu'on va se
retrouver ce soir donc touche pas à mes
jeux télé avec toute l'équipe du rac à
travers trois scènes droit à ce qui nous
attend c'est laurent patrick enlever le
bouchon relais prenait le micro pour les
microbes en pâtit il prenait le micro ma
patrie allez-y
et attention c'est parti on va chanter
la fiesta
camille est entre-temps il ya pas de
problème attention c'est parti vous fait
rentrer ce que vous allez c'est parti
musique onema
[Applaudissements]
marvel j'ai moi c'est toute la cèze
alors fait délaisser sa faveur
ce soir je répéterai alors tiré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
c'est un sacré jours
aux filles
galloway
m
[Musique]
puis l'enfer
il
[Musique]
merci
c'est le
[Musique]
ça
la testa
on retrouve ce soir tu as pu sauter
ayew
pas de patrick sébastien merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]